i would totally suck
kevin hart's black dick that would
probably be funny yeah
oh yeah that feels good oh not like that
yeah oh yeah that hurts oh we'll
probably be making you know witty
observations and
yeah bantering
yeah
probably anointed him if i was blowing
him or you just start choking because
you were laughing so hard that's true
one or the other will occur
this is a will not a
fantasy talk this isn't this is a
definite thing
hey what's up i'm ryan wright and i'm
jerry welcome to reasons to see but
we're going to give you some reasons to
see and maybe not to see right along so
let's ride
reason to see number one
it's a good time
so we just saw a ride-along we did we
watched it because it made like a [ __ ]
ton of money this weekend and uh got
horrible reviews
yeah i got really bad reviews i got like
a 24 around tomatoes okay i watched it
expecting to see some like really
horrible comedy but honestly i thought
it was really funny i was cracking up a
lot of the time this movie to me is is
honestly exactly what i expected it to
be in a good way it's like it's not
particularly great you know the script
isn't
all that inspired or anything and it's
not like shockingly original but it's a
good time yeah it's a lot of fun it's
like it's certainly formulaic without a
doubt like early on we even looked at
each other and we predicted some stuff
so yeah it's predictable sure but at the
end of the day it's just about having
fun it's called ride-along it's got the
that perfect you know save the cat
structure to it where it's like when
it's fun and games it's really just fun
and games but the fun doesn't ever
really stop it's a really fun movie it's
a cop movie technically and nothing
makes sense in terms of how police work
actually works but that's not what it's
about it's like it's it's just about
being enjoyable and being fun and that's
what's great about this movie you know
reason to see number two
kevin hot
you know who really elevates this movie
kevin hart
kevin hart i love him as a comic like a
stand-up comedian but [ __ ] man this he
owned this movie dude he is the reason
to see yeah he's the main reason to
watch this film yeah he's great without
him i mean the cast is good without him
though it would not be anywhere near as
enjoyable because it's his persona and
his charisma and his wit and just the
his mannerisms and stuff that make it so
much fun and watching him play off of
ice cube because of that he's such a
fascinating person because he's got that
like you know like this is what i love
about watching his stand-up he's got
that like eager interest like a young
boy and he's like confident but he's
also very insecure yeah you know gets
very scared he gets scared easily gets
self-conscious easily the way he
communicates at all it seems so like
natural and from within you know it's
such a natural performance you know he's
just obviously having a good time and
he's [ __ ] committed throughout the
whole thing i mean he is a really good
comedic actor like i never i never
didn't believe him you know he's perfect
in this movie yeah me cracking up man i
mean even when even when the the writing
isn't perfect he's he still elevates it
yeah even when scenes aren't so great
you'll still find yourself cracking up
at something he says or does even like
some of his physical comedy i thought
was really funny and i i rarely laugh at
like physical comedy but that and some
stuff actually had me cracking up man
yeah good times good times
reason to see number three
kevin hart and ice cube
ice cube's really good too but really
it's more so ice cube and kevin hart is
really good ice cube's okay there are
moments where he does you know shine a
little bit i feel like he's not that
good of an actor but him playing off
kevin hart is really fun to watch and
there are a lot of moments where i did
appreciate ice cube for himself as well
i think ice cube's a pretty decent actor
he's a like he's not a bad actor but
there are times where i can really tell
that he's acting there's a way he speaks
sometimes and like mannerisms where i'm
like that's an ice cube that's he's
acting like ice cube right now like
there he has these mannerisms that are
sort of specific to me honestly at the
end of the day for me i felt like
there's no one else i'd rather watch in
this role to play off kevin hart
i guess i mean he's who else could have
done it jerry i've seen him be more
solid performance wise i will defend ice
cube to the grave ryan's consensus a
surprisingly not so shitty comedy is the
reason to see right along a surprisingly
not so shitty comedy is the reason to
see right along yeah i thought this
movie was gonna suck but you know kevin
hart and uh just well mainly kevin hart
really made this movie fun jerry's
consensus a fun comedy and a good
comedic performance from kevin hart are
the reasons to see right along a fun
comedy and a good comedic performance
from kevin hart are the reasons to see
ride a law yeah you know it's a good
time it's a lot of fun and kevin hart
and ice cube playing off each other make
this movie kevin hart is hilarious it's
i i can't imagine you won't have fun
got anything else more to say about ice
cube that sucks
i didn't think i thought he was good all
right guys thanks for checking out our
review for right along why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell me who would you like to go on a
ride along with and once you're done
with that once you come over here click
this bouton so you can see more episodes
of reasons to see and last but certainly
jerry can back me up on this one not
least not the least not least if you
want to get updated every time one of
our reviews or videos is out subscribe
hit that button yeah people good sync
today we get to sing yeah we really got
the timing down on that way very good i
remember last time yeah man i think we'd
be getting like the ride and long sequel
like they made it straight to dvd
version yeah yeah that's
that's where i believe our talent is at
straight to dvd